auf der suche nach einem gemeinsamen weg
die nato sieht die größten
herausforderungen für das bündnis in
china und russland ist bald schluss mit
der masken pflicht der
bundesgesundheitsminister meint ja
schrittweise und erstmal draußen andere
mahnen zur vorsicht und staat für die
mission titelgewinn die deutsche
nationalmannschaft macht sich in münchen
bereit für ihr erstes em spiel gegen
weltmeister frankreich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers wurden abend hinein
und willkommen in einer neuen woche
gemeinsam mit kristin otto für den sport
wird spannend
die nato sieht neben russland zunehmend
auf china als strategischen rivalen
sie versucht den globalen einfluss der
neuen großmacht unter kontrolle zu
halten
wie das ist ein großes thema auf dem
ersten nato gipfel mit us präsident joe
biden der ist auch die treibende kraft
hinter der neuen härteren linie
gegenüber china aus brüssel berichtet
anne gellinek betont gut gelaunt springt
der amerikanische präsident aus der nato
blauen kulisse er will eine erneuerte
transatlantische allianz schmieden
wir vertrauen einander wieder und wir
brauchen einander so die botschaft von
die nato liegt im entschiedenen
interesse amerikas und wenn es sie nicht
gäbe müsste man sie erfinden
hinter den kulissen aber wird tacheles
geredet die beziehungen zu russland
befinden sich auf einem neuen tiefpunkt
demonstrativ trifft sich die beiden mit
den präsidenten der baltischen staaten
die sich von russland besonders bedroht
fühlen
auch china bezeichnet die nato erstmals
als einen systemischen rivalen
die usa versuchen die allianz auf klare
kante gegen peking einzuschwören
wir müssen die herausforderungen die der
aufstieg chinas für unsere sicherheit
bedeutet anpacken
auch wenn viele verbündete starke
wirtschaftliche beziehungen zu china
unterhalten wie deutschland zum beispiel
nicht allen europäern gefällt dieser
scharfe anti china kurs die kanzlerin
lässt eine hintertür zum dialog offen
china ist rivale in vielen fragen und
china ist gleichzeitig auch partner für
viele fragen ich finde es ganz wichtig
ähnlich wie wir es bei russland ja auch
machen immer das angebot zu einem
politischen gespräch zu einem
politischen diskurs aufzuführen
auch nach innen versucht die nato die
reihen zu schließen
merkel makro und in diesen minuten auch
joe biden treffen sich mit dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan dessen
militäraktionen immer wieder nato in
dreßen zuwider laufen es ist nicht mehr
und nicht weniger als der versuch eines
neustarts der transatlantischen allianz
ja wir haben gerade schon gehört es gibt
jetzt ein ganz besonders langes gespräch
von präsident biden mit dem türkischen
präsidenten erdogan ein nato partner mit
dem es nicht immer einfach war in der
vergangenheit unter krueger beobachtet
das für uns in brüssel guten abend gibt
es denn jetzt auch eine neue linie der
usa gegenüber der türkei ja zumindest
lässt die tatsache dass diese beiden
ebenso bei den ultra chip recep tayyip
erdogan immer noch zusammensetzen
diese tatsache lässt doch tief blicken
so ein nato hauptquartier das ist keine
telefonzelle und trotzdem gilt hier
trotzdem die ansage fasse dich kurz 30
staats und regierungschefs lassen ja
heute für zweieinhalb stunden zusammen
da hatte jeder fünf minuten redezeit nun
aber gleich im anschluss ein treffen von
zwei stunden und noch länger zwischen
joe biden und erdogan daraus kann man
zwei dinge ablesen einmal dass die liste
der probleme sehr langes in libyen in
syrien und eben auch beim kauf
russischer waffensysteme da handelt die
türkei fortlaufend gegen die interessen
ihrer partner in der nato und zum
zweitens kann man daraus ablesen dass
offensichtlich da die hoffnung groß ist
dass man wieder besser zusammenarbeiten
kann unter diesen beiden präsidenten und
zumindest zusammenarbeiten in der sache
da könnte der flughafen von kabul ein
versuchsballon sein
den könnten türkische truppen sichern
wenn die nato dann auf aus afghanistan
abgezogen ist also beides leute lassen
durchblicken jedes problem dass hier
abgeräumt wird dass joe biden hier noch
abräumen kann
das stärkt seine machtposition für das
gespräch am mittwoch mit wladimir putin
sagt gunnar krüger live in brüssel
gunnar herzlichen dank dafür
es knirscht zwischen den mächten dieser
welt dazu passt der bericht des
friedensforschungsinstituts sipri in
diesem jahr sei die bedrohung durch das
atomwaffenarsenal wieder größer geworden
zwar sei die zahl der sprengköpfe
sprengköpfe leicht gesunken auf
geschätzt 13.000 80 das sind 320 weniger
als im vorjahr allerdings würden die
bestände gerade weltweit modernisiert
wird und deshalb seien mehr atomwaffen
einsatzbereit
insgesamt verfügen russland und die usa
zusammen über gut 90 prozent der
sprengköpfe die anderen sieben
atommächte liegen weit dahinter
unser nächstes thema heute haben die
zahl der neuen corona infektion
entwickeln sich aktuell weiter positiv
zum ersten mal seit september werden
weniger als 1000 an einem tag in
deutschland gemeldet das
robert-koch-institut hat 549 neue fälle
registriert das sind 568 weniger als vor
einer woche zehn todesfälle kamen binnen
24 stunden dazu die sieben tage incident
sinkt auf 16,6 die korona zahlen sinken
also das befeuert natürlich auch die
diskussion über die zukunft der masken
pflicht der mund nasenschutz draußen
kann in einem ersten schritt
grundsätzlich entfallen sagt
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
doch es gibt auch stimmen die zur
vorsicht mahnen britta spiekermann hat
mehr dazu die temperaturen steigen die
inzidenz werte sinken die altstadt in
mainz die maske ist noch ein muss das
leben ist es die maske auf mich stolz
auf mich und mir ist es lieber als wir
müssen in 14 tagen macht alles wieder
dicht die tall wette verziert maske
abzunehmen so waren und instanzen so
niedrig deswegen wäre das so ich werde
dafür ganz ganz toll
die fdp fordert das ende der masken
pflicht wir instanzen haben längere zeit
unter 35 gibt es keine rechtsgrundlage
mehr für grundrechts einschränkende
maßnahmen zu denen auch die maske
pflicht gehört sie ist das aufzugeben in
sachsen wurde bereits beschlossen die
masken schlichtern schulen auszusetzen
in mecklenburg vorpommern wird ab morgen
ein ausstiegsszenario beraten
der bundesgesundheitsminister plädierte
heute über seinen sprecher für ein
gestuftes vorgehen in einem ersten
schritt kann die masse nicht draußen
grundsätzlich in fallen
das bezieht sich auf den aktuellen
zustand in der tat für konzerte müssen
allerdings oder oder zusammenkünfte
müssen allerdings hygiene konzepte
gelten die werden regional festgesetzt
ausdrücklich zur vorsicht mahnt die
linkspartei ich würde auch mit sicht auf
eine mögliche vierte wenn davon ausgehen
dass auch die masse nicht weiterhin
gelten sollte
draußen könnten die masken sofort fallen
sagen aerosol forscher in innenräumen
aber lauerten nach wie vor gefahren
gerade in kleinen von vielen personen
genutzten räumen
dort sollte schon aus dem eigeninteresse
darüber nachdenken gegebenenfalls eine
maske aufzusetzen
die zeichen stehen auf lockerungen der
senat in berlin berät morgen es könnte
sein dass masken auf belebten straßen
und plätzen auch hier bald eingepackt
werden können auch apotheken können
jetzt einen digitalen impfpass
ausstellen theoretisch denn zum start
heute vormittag hat der ansturm erst
einmal die server lahmgelegt der
apothekerverband bittet um geduld und
dass nicht alle sofort losstürmen
denn mittlerweile haben knapp 22
millionen menschen beide impfungen das
sind gut 26 prozent der bevölkerung
es werden regten jetzt mit details zum
impfpass auf dem handy eine szene wie
sie wohl heute morgen in vielen
deutschen apotheken zu sehen war die
netzwerk leitungen zum
robert-koch-institut sind zunächst
überlastet das dauerte eine weile bis es
den so lange erwarteten digitalen
impfnachweis endlich gibt die qr-codes
kommen aus dem drucker pro impfung eine
din a4 seite liegt darauf kann man in
der neuen coface oder der korona wann
app speichern
dieses zertifikat kann dann jeder
beliebig oft mit der frei verfügbaren
kopatschek überprüfen
alle sind erleichtert das ist auch jetzt
hinter sich haben weil viele doch jetzt
gerade gesagt haben dass die nächsten
tage
und dass sie das dokument in der hand
haben und alles erledigt ist sozusagen
vielen arztpraxen ist der
organisationsaufwand noch zu groß um
nachträglich für schon vollständig
geimpften patienten qr-codes auszugeben
grundsätzlich sagen wir immer man soll
sich dort den digitalen ausweis holen wo
man sich hat impfen lassen
nur wenn es gar nicht anders geht weil
der arzt nicht da ist oder man nicht
mehr zu ihm kommt dann kann man sich an
anderen arzt wenden oder in eine
apotheke im regelfall dürfte die
apotheke er zeit haben als der arzt für
die impfzentren gibt es zwei lösungen
die qr-codes kommen per post oder es
wird online portale geben das
entscheidet jede region für sich aber
erst im juli ist das digitale im
zertifikat überall in europa gültig
wichtig aber bleibt ob qr code oder im
heft zum gültigen impfnachweis gehört
ein personalausweis das nämlich ist der
einzige schutz gegen fälschungen
großbritannien wollte bei corona ab
nächster woche eigentlich in großem stil
zurück in die alte freiheit doch das
wird jetzt wohl verschoben die zuerst
den indien registrierte delta variante
breitet sich nämlich rasant aus vor
allem in england ist sie vorherrschend
und lässt die infektionszahlen wieder in
die höhe schnellen
zuletzt wurden mehr als 6000
neuinfektionen am tag registriert die
inzidenz steigt seit wochen
besondere sorge bereitet der regierung
das delta hochansteckend ist andreas
stamm vorfreude auf den tag der freiheit
sieht anders aus in immer mehr delta
hotspots in nordengland schwärmen
testteams auf der suche nach
unentdeckten fällen der erstmals in
indien nachgewiesenen variante wie hier
in der region köln ließ werden sie immer
häufiger fündig wir haben mehr als 2000
tests an der haustür gemacht 5000 in
betroffenen schulen so haben wir 175
positive fälle aufgespürt
asymptomatische die wir sonst nie in der
ketten was delta so gefährlich macht sie
ist ansteckend wie keine bislang die
gefahr im krankenhaus zu landen ist für
infizierte doppelt so groß nur wer
zweifach geimpft ist hat einen hohen
schutz vor einem schweren verlauf und
die fallzahlen steigen seit wochen
exponentiell
die große frage ist wie viele der
infizierten dieser dritten welle müssen
ins krankenhaus da schon 55 prozent
aller erwachsenen doppelt geimpft sind
dürfte es nicht an die schlimmsten
annahmen run reichen aber wir wissen
noch nicht exakt wie schlimm es werden
kann
aus angst vor wie der überfüllten
krankenhäusern dürfte die regierung den
geplanten wegfall aller einschränkungen
am 21 juni um vier wochen verschieben
zeit in der weitere zehn millionen
menschen ihre zweite impfung bekommen
die schlechte nachricht wird erwartet
verkündet boris johnson in diesen
minuten per tv ansprache
der premier ist sofort nach dem nato
gipfel nach london geeilt wo nicht nur
kritiker johnson fragen werden ob er
gegen expertenrat einreisen aus indien
zu lange erlaubt habe und deshalb der
freiheitstag erst mal ausfällt so der
premierminister hat jetzt auch gerade
schon gesprochen der freiheitstag wird
erstmal verschoben andreas stamm in
london guten abend wie gefährlich ist
denn die lage in großbritannien aktuell
ja immerhin so gefährlich dass eben
diese verschiebung aus sicht der
regierung notwendig ist und boris
johnson ist kein mann der das
leichtfertig getan hat er hasst diese
art von einschränkungen das ist
sicherlich in den letzten 15 monaten der
pandemie klage klar geworden er wird
sehr viel politischen druck bekommen aus
seiner eigenen partei so viele sagen das
schade der wirtschaft so schlimm seien
die zahlen noch gar nicht warum das
ganze und die opposition die wird ihm
vorwerfe neben er aber viel zu lange
gezögert einreisen aus indien zu
verbieten
deshalb hat sich delta hier in
großbritannien breit machen können aber
man muss sagen es ist ja eine
verschiebung eine vorsichtsmaßnahme
mangels wissen es gibt einfach noch
nicht genügend daten und geld trifft
eben auf eine bevölkerung die wirklich
viele viele viele geimpfte hat und auch
viele genesene und insofern lässt sich
abschließend nicht klären wie gefährlich
das ist dass sagt die wissenschaft dafür
braucht man zeit deshalb die
verschiebung aber man kann vielleicht
schon drei lehren ziehen sagen hier
viele erstens zweifach impfen ist das
gebot der stunde ist ein absoluter
schutz aber es hilft enorm
jede welle abzuflachen zweitens es wird
wieder eine debatte entfacht werden
sicherlich dass man minderjährige unter
18 jährige impfen sollte um sicher zu
sein denn da ist die zahl der
infektionen der neuinfektionen riesig
und drittens nicht zu früh freuen im
taumel der eröffnung
schritte haben viele vergessen hier in
großbritannien das und daran erinnert
delta
die pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei
andreas vielen dank und dann stellt sich
natürlich die frage wie sieht es bei uns
aus wie stark hat sich die delta
variante in deutschland verbreitet und
wie viel sorgen müssen wir uns machen
julia schröter jetzt auf der suche nach
antworten ein studentenwohnheim in
dresden vor einigen tagen wurde es
vollständig unter quarantäne gestellt
ein student ein gebürtiger inder hatte
sich mit der gefährlichen delta variante
angesteckt und war daran gestorben
der junge mann war zuvor in indien
gewesen infiziert hatte er sich aber mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit bei einem
bekannten in dresden 170 studenten
mussten zum testergebnis 7 corona fälle
bei dreien ist die delta variante
wahrscheinlich ein extremer fall
doch insgesamt ist die ansteckende
corona mutation in deutschland noch
relativ selten
ihr anteil liegt seit drei wochen bei
etwa drei prozent ganz anders die lage
in großbritannien woran liegt das
ein möglicher grund dafür ist dass es in
großbritannien vermutlich mehr
rückkehrer gegeben hat aus indien im
märz und april
und dass man dadurch sozusagen der
eintragungen dieser variante hatte
könnte sich die delta variante auch in
deutschland stark ausbreiten
experten können das schlecht voraussagen
aber sie wissen wie man vorbeugen kann
regionale eindämmung immer dann wenn sie
jetzt auftritt langsamer und bedachte
öffnung des strategien aufrechterhalten
gerade auch in bildungseinrichtungen
dabei sind tests in schulen besonders
wichtig das zeigen studien aus
großbritannien
auch deutsche wissenschaftler haben
inzwischen einen guten überblick wo und
wie oft die delta variante auftritt das
macht es möglich früh zu reagieren und
dann das impfen
besonders die zweite impfung sei
entscheidend für den schutz gegen delta
sagen virologen je mehr menschen schnell
folge impft sind desto besser anderes
thema jetzt ist kann jedem passieren
schneller als man möglicherweise denkt
gut verlust nach einer operation oder
einem unfall eine blutkonserve muss her
um leben zu retten
doch die spender werden rat zu wenige
junge kommen nach gab es 2011 auf 1000
einwohner noch 95 blutspenden waren es
2009/10 nur noch 79 3 prozent der
deutschen gehen regelmäßig zum spenden
es müssten aber doppelt so viele seien
sagen ärzte und helfer heute am
weltblutspendetag andreas linke
berichtet blut das leben retten kann und
das nicht nur nach schwerem unfall und
blutverlust leukämie erkrankte sind
ebenfalls angewiesen auf die
spendenbereitschaft
diese patienten bekommt wöchentlich
einen beutel im kampf gegen ihren
blutkrebs patienten die stammzellen
transplantiert werden knochenmark
transplantiert werden sind abhängig von
blutkonserven sie brauchen fast täglich
blutkonserven zum teil auch mehrere
konten in der phase der überwachung nach
transplantation
auch wenn sie am klinikum stuttgart noch
nicht von engpässen sprechen wollen die
lücken in den kühlschränken sind
deutlich der bedarf steigt weil
krankenhäuser konerding verschobene op
es nachholen
gleichzeitig sinkt in der sommer- und
urlaubszeit die zahl der spender die
vielleicht auch durch gruner
verunsichert sind
doch auch geimpfte und genesene dürfen
spenden wie die chefin der blutbank sagt
die korona als erkranken nicht wirklich
eine rolle als eine übertragung über gut
ist nahezu ausgeschlossen
die impfung spielt für das blut auch
keine rolle also man darf wenn man
genesen ist und wenn man geimpft ist
jederzeit blutspenden wer selber im
medizinischen bereich arbeitet kennt die
dringlichkeit dr christian görke spendet
seit vielen jahren
jeder hat genügend und jeder der gesund
ist verdienen wollte das an meiner
meinung nach einfach selbstverständlich
sein
aber denkt gibt vielen menschen denen
das gar nicht bewusst ist
blut spenden eine direkte form des
sozialen engagements darauf verweist der
welttag der blutspende wichtiger hinweis
so jetzt was ganz anderes in der sendung
denn die ich schon so ein bisschen
kribbelt es geht los
die deutsche mannschaft läuft ja
eigentlich schon
alles raushauen so die devise des
bundestrainers joachim löw löw für die
große herausforderung gleich zu beginn
gegen weltmeister frankreich morgen
abend in münchen wohl wissen dass ein
deutsches team bei einer eben noch nie
ein auftaktspiel verloren hat noch
einmal schlafen dann sollten sie aber
hellwach sein die deutschen spieler es
geht schließlich gegen frankreich der
weltmeister bittet zum tanz jeder
spieler ist bereit von uns dass wir
einen hoffentlich erfolgreiches turnier
starten können und wir starten natürlich
gegen eine top-mannschaft hopp oder topp
gleich zum auftakt ein echter härtetest
für die mannschaft von joachim löw die
ja zuletzt nicht immer überzeugen konnte
ist eine gute stimmung in der mannschaft
aber auch sehr viel ehrgeiz und
tatendrang zu spüren
von daher sind wir gut gerüstet das gilt
auch für das personal bis auf jonas
hofmann konnten alle am
abschlusstraining teilnehmen
zwei treffer des bundesliga stürmers
patrick schick von bayer leverkusen
haben tschechien in der gruppe d eine
verheißungsvolle nennt roten einstieg
beschert 210 0 in glasgow
bei einem der elf em gastgeber
schottland
die schottischen fans trauten ihren
augen nicht es war ein geniestreich ein
absolutes traumtor dass die partie
entschied patrick aus gut 50 metern zum
2 0
der stürmer von bayer leverkusen sah in
der 52 minute dass der schottische
torhüter marshall viel zu weit vor dem
tor stand und netzte fast von der
mittellinie aus ein dass der wohl
bislang schönste treffer der em die
gäste besser und einfacher effizienter
als tapfer kämpfende schotten patrick
schick war es auch der die tschechen
kurz vor der pause in führung brachte
ein klasse kopfball des stürmers r
bester spieler der partie tschechien
verdirbt den schotten in glasgow die
party feiert einen perfekten auftakt und
spanien schweden nachher live hier bei
uns im zdf für den 8 ein paar von diesen
treffen können noch gebrauchen weil die
sonst vielen dank christian so dann habe
ich auch das wetter für sie sonne und
hitze aber nicht überall gleich mehr von
osten telli die kolleginnen und kollegen
vom heute-journal in der halbzeitpause
um 10 vor 10 mit marietta slomka wir
freuen uns auf sie morgen wieder biss
dann in allen einen sehr angenehm
[Musik]
ein schön genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das hier ist
unsere atmosphäre von der
internationalen raumstation ausgesehen
sie ist relativ schmal und in diesem
schmalen band spielt sich alles ab
die atmosphäre heizt sich weiter auf das
spüren wir auch in deutschland die
hitzetage die haben seit 1951 zugenommen
um 196 prozent und hitze gibt es auch in
den nächsten tagen zum beispiel schon
morgen im süden deutschlands da wird es
heiß bis 31 grad aber diese kaltfront
bringt kühlere luft aber nur im norden
kühlt es dann ab so sieht die nacht aus
von norden her kommen die wolken rein
ansonsten klart es auf und die
temperaturen sinken auf 8 grad im
südosten deutschlands und 15 grad im
westen
lüften sie noch mal kräftig durch es
wird ja morgen heiß im tagesverlauf dann
kommen die wolken weiter in die mitte
voran im süden scheint verbreitet die
sonne bei höchsten temperaturen bis 31
grad im südwesten und 19 grad an der
nordsee hitze gibt es auch in den
nächsten tagen und zwar am mittwoch bis
34 grad donnerstag bis 36 grad und am
freitag kommt von westen her kräftige
schauer und gewitter auf
ein schöner abend